في بلده بيت فوريك في الضفه الغربيه اصيب
عدد من الفلسطينيين في اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للبلده الواقعه شرق
نابلس وياتي هذا في وقت تستمر فيه
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه في قلقيليه
والخليل وبيت لحم كما اقتحمت قوات وشرطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك في القدس لمنع المصلين من
الاعتكاف والصلاه بمناسبه ذكرى ليله
الاسرائ والمعراج ونشر الجيش الاسرائيلي
قواته في محيط وداخل البلده القديمه في
القدس المحتله تزامنا مع مسيره استفزازيه
ليهود متدينين انطلقت وجابت ازقه البلده
وابواب المسجد الاقصى باتجاه حائط البراق
وكانت مجموعات كبيره من المستوطنين اقتحمت
البلده القديمه ورددوا شعارات عنصريه تحت
حمايه قوات الاحتلال كما شهد الرئيس
الارجنتيني اثناء مشاركته لمستوطنين رقصات
وصفت بالاستفزاز
داخل ساحه حائط الب
وراق معنا من رام الله مراسلنا محمد خيري
ومن الخليل مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار محمد
مجمل ما يحدث ايضا في
الضفه الغربيه بما بما في ذلك ما يحدث في
باحات المسجد
الاقصى نعم عثمان ما جرى في المسجد الاقصى
هي مسيره استفزازيه لعدد ك مئات من
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين جابوا حواري
مدينه القدس البلده القديمه خاصه في مدينه
القدس والى جوار ابواب المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وهناك رددوا شعارات تلمود
وشعارات استفزازيه ضد المواطنين
الفلسطينيين والعرب في المكان كما فعليا
كما ذكر قبل قليل في تقريركم ان الرئيس
الارجنتيني شهد ايضا خلال تاديته رقصات مع
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين في باحه حائط
البراق ايضا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نصبت الحواجز على ابواب ومداخل البلده
القديمه في مدينه القدس وكذلك ابواب
المسجد الاقصى لمنع المصلين الفلسطينيين
من الدخول الى المسجد الاقصى وخاصه من غير
سكان مدينه القدس ودققت في هويات جميع
الداخلين الى المسجد كما انتشرت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في باحات المسجد
الاقصى لمنع اعتكاف المواطنين الفلسطينيين
داخل المسجد وخاصه في المسجد القبلي من
المسجد الاقصى وكذلك اطلقت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع
باتجاه حشود للشبان الفلسطينيين في منطقه
راس العمود جنوبي المسجد الاقصى يبدو ان
هذه المسيره الاستفزازيه تاتي في ظل احياء
الفلسطينيين ذكرى الاسراء والمعراج
والدعوات الفلسطينيه للوجود في المسجد
الاقصى واداء الصلاه داخل المسجد الذي
يتعرض لتضييق مستمر من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بشكل مكثف خاصه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وحتى هذا اليوم فيما يتعلق في
الضفه الغربيه في اخر التطورات هي
المواجهات التي اندلعت في بلده بيت فوريك
شرقي مدينه نابلس الواقعه في شمال الضفه
الغربيه اقتحمت قوات عسكريه اسرائيليه هذه
القريه كما سير جنود جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي جنود المشاه في شوارع القريه
وحاصروا مبان سكنيه وهناك اندلعت مواجهات
مع الشبان الفلسطينيين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اطلقت الرصاص الحي باتجاه
المواطنين الفلسطينيين ما ادى الى اصابه
خمسه شبان اربعه منهم بالرصاص الحي
والخامس اصيب
بشض بشض ايه رصاصه
اسرائيليه ولكن ايضا قوات الاحتلال حاولت
منع سيارات الاسعاف من اسعاف الجرحى وكذلك
اعتدت على طاقم اسعاف وعلى جريح داخل
سياره الاسعاف